trois défis communisme communisante
vérité
d'hommes semblables et ibo
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique
je suis fier vitaly cofondateur de
scopeo et je vous souhaite la bienvenue
sur ce dixième épisode de notre série
l'entrevue politique
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux de
recevoir le politologue éditorialistes
monsieur guillaume bigot
mais avant tout je laisse la parole à
lucas da silva également co-fondateur de
scopeo pour qu'ils puissent poser le
décor de ce nouveau podcast
et oui merci pierre bonjour à celles et
ceux qui nous écoutent et surtout
bonjour à vous monsieur guillaume vidot
bonjour messieurs pierre vitaly et du
canada si pas et bonjour à toutes et à
tous vous nous fait le plaisir
aujourd'hui de nous accorder cette
entrevue pour discuter ensemble de
sujets relatifs à notre identité
nationale à l'immigration et surtout à
l'assimilation culturelle des personnes
étrangères en france mais avant de
démarrer entrevue monsieur bigot je vous
laisse vous présenter brièvement pour
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent
d'accord au bepc sera très bref j'ai une
activité professionnelle qui est de
diriger un établissement d'enseignement
supérieur en fait une école supérieure
de commerce
j'ai une deuxième activité
professionnelle qui est d'être
éditorialiste sur la chaîne ses news et
puis j'ai aussi écrit pas mal de livres
l'âge c'est mon dixième libre aux
éditions plon qui s'appelle populo
phobie pourquoi il faut remplacer la
classe dirigeante française donc je
travaillais sur des sujets assez
différent comme le management d'akka
trahison des chefs chez fayard les
questions géopolitiques et le danger de
l'islamisme notamment en 2005 a testé on
arrive le jour où la transe tremblera et
puis des livres sur des pins disons-le
et comment des crises régionales peuvent
devenir des crises mondiales et ramener
disons la guerre à l'époque on parlait
beaucoup il est trop jeune mais on était
les années 2000 tournant des années 2000
on parlait beaucoup beaucoup de
mondialisation heureuse et donc m'étais
inscrit en faux j'ai fait un livre après
midi qui s'appelait les sept scénarios
de l'apocalypse en 2000 où j'allais
enfin où il était question de ben laden
attaquant new york et d'une grande
offensive de l'islamisme entre autres
mais aussi par exemple d'un choc
militaire peut-être à venir entre
direct ou indirect entre la entre la
chine et les états unis en mer de chine
voilà d'accord merci alors on va essayer
de poser un petit peu ensemble le les
termes que l'on utilisera autour de tout
au long de cette entrevue est en effet
lorsque l'on traite de la question de
l'accueil des étrangers
on note une différence dans l'opinion
dans le débat public sur entre
l'intégration et l'assimilation
alors vous quelles différences vous
faites monsieur entre justement cette
intégration et cette assimilation et
vedène vous pencher à titre personnel
mans alors c'est très simple d'abord est
ce qu'on parle de l'accueil d'étrangers
en france qu'il s'agisse de gens qui
sont des étudiants par exemple étrangers
j'en ai dans mon école ou qu'il s'agisse
de deux jeux de gens qui travaillent
alors il ya moins de en théorie la plus
d'immigration de travail non qualifiés
sont plutôt des cadres des cadres reçues
et là il faut parler le terme correct
française c'est de parler d'intégration
bonne intégration 50 on reste longtemps
dans un pays qui n'est pas le sien
il faut viser à s'intégrer c'est à dire
à essayer de ne pas trop respect entre
expatriés et puis généralement ça se
paie par le travail ça ça peut se faire
aussi quand on est expatrié dans un pays
qui n'est pas le sien
on peut nouer des relations avec les
parents d'élèves de l'école de ses
enfants si on a des enfants scolarisés à
l'étranger etc
voilà on va on va dire que c'est ce
faire la meilleure place possible quand
on réside sur plus ou moins long terme
dans un pays qui n'est pas le sien c'est
ça l'intégration et c'est très
intéressant que nos élites
je n'aime pas trop utiliser ce terme
parce que je pense que depuis les
mérovingiens on n'a jamais eu la
dirigeante aussi stupide en réalité non
notamment en france
nos élites entre guillemets donc parle
d'intégration et utilise ce terme pour
parler en fait deux d'autres choses à
dire de l'assimilation à l'assimilation
ce sont toujours des étrangers qui vont
dans un pays qui n'est pas le leur mais
ils ont décidé d'y faire souche c'est à
dire de s'y installer définitivement
c'est à dire en réalité de d'y être
enterrée et enterrer ses morts dont 20
pays c'est très important et puis il ya
l'idée aussi que
un immigré est donc les enfants vont
devenir les nationaux du pays soit même
d'ailleurs changer de nationalité
et donc là il ya un phénomène
d'assimilation alors l'assimilation
c'est très différent de l'intégration
l'intégration ça suppose d'avoir un
travail de payer ses impôts
enfin voilà d'avoir une vie disons la
meilleure possible et peut-être de nouer
des liens avec les autochtones où les
indigènes l'assimilation c'est devenir
soi-même un auto devenir soi-même un
indigène quand on ne l'est pas à
l'origine c'est à dire quand on est dans
un autre pays
et ça c'est très différent donc des
français expatrié aux états unis peuvent
être bien intégré dans la société
américaine s'ils sont les expatriés y
revenir en france et des français aux
états unis peuvent être assimilés s'il
décide de devenir américain si leurs
enfants sont américains c'est un gars un
garçon américain un garçon français
épouser une américaine ou une fille
française épousé un américain avec elle
pas s'assimiler au pays
donc voilà donc la différence c'est quoi
il ya une simulation en linguistique
bien sûr mais il ya une assimilation
culturelle celle des moeurs des façons
de faire et de ne pas faire les choses
qui sont très différentes même dans un
pays comme les etats-unis qui est pas si
différent de la france
il y a quand même dix ont des habitudes
qui sont pas les mêmes
on va socialiser souvent dans les
églises ailleurs le dimanche ou dans
différentes les synagogues ou dans les
mosquées on va faire des barbecues on va
assister aux matches de baseball voilà
une partie d'eux comme ça de la culture
de tous les jours mais sinon plus
profondément il ya le fait de se sentir
américain de pouvoir éventuellement
engager sa vie pour le drapeau américain
on devient américains et on devient
partie de la nation américaine du destin
de l'histoire des états unis d'envoyer
c'est une distinction très importante
entre intégration assimilation et le
fait qu'on utilise pour des gens dont on
dit par ailleurs qu'ils ont vocation à
rester et parfois deuxième troisième
génération
on utilise le terme d'intégration eh
bien ça montre pourquoi finalement
l'assimilation ne marche pas et en fait
l'assimilation est un processus
compliqué difficile souvent douloureux
si on prend les égouts l'exemple des
états unis pays d'immigration
on voit aux états unis comme dans
beaucoup de pays d'immigration
la première génération n'est pas
sacrifiée mais en général voilà elle se
fait là une petite place dans la société
américaine quand bien même elle faire un
effort
sur la deuxième et la troisième
génération devienne pleinement américain
processus long c'est un processus
compliqué parce qu'il faut se faire à
des habitudes qui sont pas les siennes
celles son pays d'enfance et ça signifie
qu'on est soi-même un effort et ça
signifie aussi que le pays d'accueil
fait un effort pour aller vers bourg
dont il ya une rencontre est donc ce
n'est pas un processus simple ni
inévitable d'ailleurs c'est mon ami et
malika sorel qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur cette question et elle a montré que
l'émigration italienne par exemple
enfants du début du siècle il y a près
plus de la moitié de ces italiens qui
étaient venus travailler en france dans
un pays donc voisin
géographiquement et voisins
culturellement mêmes linguistiquement
qui étaient repartis chez eux parce
qu'elle n'est pas tout simplement pas
envie de s'assimiler
donc il est normal aussi que les
immigrés n'ai pas envie de s'assimiler
qu'il ya un échec et qui repartent chez
eux
mais l'ugtt il le fait non utilise ce
terme la montre bien que notre
assimilation elle est vouée à l'échec
parce que nous même ne voulons plus a
signé merci monsieur bigot pour ses
premières définition très claire qui
permettent de poser les termes qu'on
utilisera tout au long de l'entrevue
alors justement pour rebondir sur ce
modèle classique d'assimilation beaucoup
disent qu'aujourd'hui ce modèle se
trouve en crise
alors pour quelles raisons selon vous
celui ci fonctionne moins bien
aujourd'hui
est ce dû aux différentes vagues
d'immigration particulièrement
extra-européenne des dernières décennies
est-ce plutôt à cause d'une économie
française au ralenti qui peinent à
offrir le plein emploi et des conditions
de vie décente à tous les habitants de
france ou encore est ce qu'on pourrait
l'expliquer par des discriminations dans
les étrangers qui peuvent pousser à un
certain repli sur soi sur ce thème on
peut évidemment penser au fait que les
populations immigrées se retrouvent
souvent regroupés dans des banlieues en
périphérie des grandes villes ce qui ne
favorise évidemment pas la simulation
avec la culture française
ok alors peut-être au bo commencé par
tordre le coup à deux des légendes
urbaines mais des idées complètement
fausse
la première idée fausse et que il y
aurait dix ont par rapport
si on prend la france contemporaine par
rapport au point de repère grâce à la
culture française contemporaine 1,1
degré d'écartement mais un mystique
culturelle des moeurs ou 6 par rapport à
ce modèle standard et donc on dirait
bien finalement
voyez plus vous êtes éloignés de la
culture française des moeurs françaises
comme immigrés et plus votre
assimilation va être difficile et la
deuxième idée qui est fausse le
semble-t-il c'est de tout expliquer par
l'économie ou même d'ailleurs le
phénomène de ghettoïsation le
regroupement de gens dans des maisons
dans des endroits où ils sont entre
alors pourquoi
d'abord parce que ce regroupement est
assez naturel finalement y'a pas
vraiment à chocques pas être choqué par
ça c'est assez naturel que quand on
arrive dans un pays qui est différent du
sien on fasse un peu la bande à part
mais on se met un peu un peu ensemble
voyez vu l'âge et la géographie d'une
ville comme new york vous avez la petite
italie la petite chine etc
bon donc c'est pareil chez nous
aujourd'hui
yao évidemment il ya plus cette culture
du melting-pot aux états unis et cette
fameuse qui sont culture rock dont on
pourra parler peut-être plus tard mais
qui bloque peut-être un peu les
mécanismes et le regroupement
géographique et le fait de se regrouper
entre entre nationaux disons dans la
preuve quand on arrive dans un pays
comptant des bars dans un pays n'est pas
du tout aberrant c'est ce qu'elle a été
aussi les polonaises quel effet les
italiens ce qu'avaient fait les juifs
qui ont fait les maghrébins en france
etc voire même les régions d'ailleurs je
vous signale à paris à des quartiers
entiers de breton pour la gare
montparnasse pour des raisons évidentes
donc fermer cette parenthèse deuxième
question oui on va dire les bretons se
passe il les a signés c'est déjà
français et plus on est loin de la
culture française alors bon les colonels
et italiens tous ces gens là étaient des
gens catholique voire chrétiens pour
d'autres ou même les juifs étaient moins
éloignées et disons de la culture
française que de leçons
les gens du sahel par en fait je ne
crois pas du tout que ce soit vrai là je
reviens sur la première idée fausse
parce que lorsque vous êtes chinois
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup d'immigration
doublé migration chinoise une
immigration de chinois de vietnam
et puis il ya une immigration de chinois
de chine notamment du nord de la chine
assez importante qui a continué à donner
80 90 moi j'ai été dans des collèges et
qui en suit dans un lycée à paris et
collèges en banlieue parisienne
on avait des chinois beaucoup de chinois
les parents n'étaient absolument pas
assimilé la culture était mais la
planète mars
enfin cela n'avait rien à voir et en
fait on peut être de plain pied avec un
malien avec un algérien ne serait ce que
parce qu'on partage d'une langue en
commun mais je vous rappelle aussi que
même s'il y a l'islamisme qui pose un
sacré problème
en tout cas le monothéisme musulmans et
le monothéisme chrétien et dans les
soubassements de sensibilisation et nos
sociétés respectives sont pas
complètement disons totalement elles
peuvent se comprendre un minimum tandis
que la culture confucéenne chinoise est
vraiment complètement différent pourtant
vous l'avez vu et tout le monde peut le
constater les l'assimilation des chinois
est pas du tout problématique et ça se
passe très bien donc c'est l'idée d'un
d'un degrés d'écart par rapport à la
culture française à mon avis est fausse
alors pourquoi le modèle d'assimilation
est en crise il est en crise pour des
facteurs à part pour des raisons qui
sont très différentes les unes des
autres mais qui peuvent se résumer à
trois facteurs essentiels la première et
je pense que l'immigration de toute
façon était très mal parti
à partir des années 80 c'est simple
c'est que il faut plusieurs conditions
pour l'immigration fonctionné notamment
qui gagne croissance économique forte et
donc il n'y ait pas de chômage
pour une raison très simple parce que si
vous n'avez pas un besoin de main
d'oeuvre que vous avez donc une
croissance relativement faible et que
vous avez déjà du chômage
si vous faites venir des gens de
l'extérieur des travailleurs de
l'extérieur surtout pas qualifié qu'est
ce que vous allez faire vous allez les
mettre en concurrence avec vos chômeurs
nous à les faire baisser les salaires et
donc évident ça va mal se bat c'est non
seulement ils vont pas trouver de
travail vont se retrouver eux-mêmes au
chômage ce qui est tout à fait le cas
d'ailleurs et en plus vous allez près
peser à la baisse sur les salaires et
donc ça explique pourquoi
disons la classe ouvrière les gens qui
sont directement en concurrence
économique avec les immigrés qui n'ont
pas de qualification n'aime pas du tout
l'immigration
georges marchais l'avez compris au début
des années 80 le parti communiste
français avait enfourché 7
ce combat de la lutte contre
l'immigration économique au début des
années 80 était double
bien sûr par le front national est
maintenant pour le rassemblement
national mais je vous signale c'est
renier parti ouvrier de france pour
aussi essentiellement cette raison la
nôtre aborder des raisons de racisme
c'est parce qu'il ya une concurrence
directement sur les salaires et sur les
bas salaires ce que les cards ont été
reçus le vol ne voit pas ou ne veulent
pas voir d'ailleurs
donc il y as eu mes premiers acteurs
heures c'est le facteur économique si
vous n'avez pas besoin d'emplois faire
venir des gens en très grande quantité
on a à peu près en lice est sûre depuis
les années 80 90 2000 2010 et 2020 on a
à peu près une moyenne de 300 mille deux
cent cinquante mille trois cent mille
personnes qui viennent chaque année pour
ne pas repartir vous voyez c'est quand
même considérable et donc dans ces
conditions c'est très mal parti puisque
n'est pas suffisamment d'emplois
la deuxième raison c'est la raison non
pas de la distance culturelle mais d'un
ressentiment ressentiment oui coloniale
c'est vrai ressentiment particulier le
poids de la guerre d'algérie et puis ce
ressentiment il s'est brutalement
enflammé avec la montée de l'islamisme
dans les pays de départ et puis c'est un
phénomène planétaire se réveille qui est
à la fois un réveil l'on peut dire de
l'islam sunnite
mais c'est un réveil de l'islam sunnite
est peut-être ça recombinaison disons
avec quelque chose qui ressemble un peu
au nazisme bolchévisme en maohi c'est
quelque chose d'un peu de totalitaire
est donc là évidemment c'est une
idéologie qui prônent la haine la
détestation le mépris des moeurs
occidentales dont les moeurs françaises
notamment
surtout que nous avons mettront vraiment
en avant la laïcité c'est une
caractéristique donc là le choc est
encore plus violent et puis surtout qui
prône carrément la conquête c'est à dire
la colonisation finalement à l'envers et
enfin parce que le gouvernement ne parle
de séparatisme est bien mignon le
gouvernement mais c'est un euphémisme
c'est à la fois pour ne pas parler de
cela misme mais c'est aussi pour faire
comme s'il voulait faire bande à part
mais ils ne veulent pas faire bande à
part
ils veulent nous imposer la charia
évidemment pas les moyens mais mais en
tout cas c'est bien leur intention en
tout cas je parle bien sûr des militants
islamistes donc la deuxième raison c'est
le comportement des gens qui arrivent
qui n'ont qu'une envie de signer et la
troisième raison est bien c'est disons
l'opinion que la plupart des français
ont de là
ans et son droit à assimiler et d'une
certaine façon la confiance que les
français ont dans les vertus de l'ours
d'or société leur culture de leurs
moeurs et disons-le à la capacité à
projeter cette cette identité française
dans l'avenir et là évidemment il ya une
énorme panne en fait pour le dire plus
simplement les français n'ont plus
confiance en eux en tant que nation ne
sont plus du tout convaincu de la force
de leur de leur identité
elle est en crise et donc si les gens
d'à du pays d'arrivée ne veulent plus
assimilé parce que ils ont honte de ce
qu'ils sont ou parce qu'ils s'estiment
vraiment trop trop laide ans dans ce
miroir et qu'ensuite les gens qui
viennent n'ont pas envie de 5000 et non
plus voir ont envie d'un projet de
conquête inverse imposer leurs moeurs et
qu'enfin vous n'avez pas de croissance
économique va toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour que ça se passe pas bien du
tout en effet comme vous l'évoquez
lorsqu'on parle d'assimilation la
question sous jacente est aussi celle de
l'immigration en reprenant les chiffres
de l'insee
on comptait en 2019 6,7 millions
d'immigrés vivant en france c'est-à-dire
10% de la population totale et 2,5
millions de ces émigrés c'est-à-dire 37%
d'entre eux ont acquis la nationalité
française et parallèlement sondage après
sondage
on note qu'une large majorité de
français considère qu'il a qu'il y
aurait trop d'immigrés en france
alors vous juste un bon comment est-ce
que vous positionner sur cette question
des migrations
y at il une nécessité de réguler ces
flux pour mieux assimiler les
populations à venir mais aussi peut-être
les populations déjà présentes sur le
territoire
et si régulation à quel échelon et
comment faire
oui comme je vous le disais la question
de la question se pose du besoin en main
d'oeuvre pour commencer du besoin en
main d'oeuvre parce que officiellement
et c'est si vous voulez il ya là il ya
véritablement un déni de démocratie
c'est une question quand même qui est en
soi pour qu'on soit contre une question
qui est majeur en fait parce qu'elle a
des tas de l'état d'application avec
d'applications sur le système social le
niveau éducatif de la jeunesse elle a
des implications sur la politique de
logement a des implications bien sûr là
là de manière extrêmement disons
spectaculaires à travers le terrorisme
c'est quelque chose le 13 la phénomène
un peu un peu limite un peu extrême
c'est pas le cas
elle a des implications bien sûr en
terme de sécurité et c'est donc la
question là ce qui est vraiment étrange
c'est que cette caisse est que cette
immigration dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui traînent vraiment massive
qui s'est déroulé à aubeterre une
immigration de peuplement que s'est
déroulée depuis accéléré avec les années
80 finalement c'est une question où les
le peuple français n'a jamais eu la
parole lui a jamais posé cette question
alors pourquoi c'est très difficile à
comprendre je pense que le
malheureusement le front national
la montée du front national dans les
années 80 a joué un rôle de verrous ça a
verrouillé ce débat salle à moraliser
aussi puisque les migrations en fait on
peut dire que c'est pas un phénomène bon
ou mauvais en soi l'immigration peut
être bonne
même une immigration disons de
maghrébine ou africaine dans une france
en pleine croissance avec une très
grande confiance en elle pourrait être
un facteur de renforcement disons de
puissance pour la france donc
l'immigration ça dépend vraiment des
conditions les conditions n'étaient plus
réunies alors c'est vraiment très
curieux qu'on n'ait jamais posé la
question notamment lors d'un référendum
au peuple français parce que c'est une
question majeure
mais surtout je pense que
la façon dont l'immigration s'est
produite
c'est ce qu'ont pierre brochant on sait
pas trop à des gse appelé les migrations
juridique c'est à dire qu'en fait
l'immigration économique elle été
officiellement stoppées
elle a été stoppée avec dès le lendemain
du premier choc pétrolier et le
ralentissement de la croissance donc les
autorités de l'époque on était ensemble
13 ont bien faire quand bien réagi
évidemment le l'économie s'arrête on va
plus faire venir des travailleurs
émigrés
par contre il y a eu une immigration
juridique qui est de deux types en fait
d'abord la première c'est le
regroupement familial c'est à dire le
fait que les tribunaux en s'appuyant sur
des conventions internationales
convention des nations unies et puis les
commandes des textes européens aussi on
considérait que le droit dabo de mener
une vie familiale normale était un droit
de l'homme et donc on considérait que
c'était strictement interdite d'empêcher
vais travailler en y était déjà là de
faire venir leurs familles et donc de
fil en aiguille vous avez toujours
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui en 2020 toujours
un flux migratoires qui est lié à ce
modèle pain qui est lié pardon à ce
fameux droit de mener une vie familiale
normale c'est-à-dire le regroupement
familial qui ça on aurait évidemment pu
en discuter ou a demandé c'était une
bonne idée ou pas une bonne idée et
notamment de faire venir des gens dans
des ghettos les accueillir dans de
mauvaises conditions dans un pays où il
ya une montée d'extrême droite etc
deuxième source d'immigration juridique
le détournement du droit d'asile le
droit d'asile évidemment c'était un
cetain on peut dire quelque chose auquel
tous les français sont très attachés a
juste droit
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment au
coeur on peut dire de notre notre
philosophie politique républicaine et
démocratique c'est-à-dire d'accueillir
de protéger les gens qui sont soit
menacée génocide
et puis qui combattent pour nos valeurs
pour la liberté là où le système devient
fou c'est que ces quelques milliers ou
quelques dizaines de milliers de gens
qui se prennent fait et cause pour la
liberté et qui sont menacés à raison de
leur engagement politique que nos
ambassades et des consulats partout dans
le monde connaisse un d'ailleurs sont
devenus des centaines de milliers et
pourquoi ils sont des centaines milliers
bien sûr parce que c'est une immigration
économique déguisé c'est un secret de
police
elle est donc là finalement c'est ce
sont deux détournements finalement de
faim le flux migratoire continue alors
que le besoin migratoire n'est plus là
donc c'est vraiment vraiment très gênant
on peut considérer aussi que pour que
l'immigration soit favorable j'ai
insisté sur la notion de croissance
économique
mais il faut aussi parler je pense de
croissance démographique alors
d'ailleurs pourquoi mais c'est très
simple parce que ce sont toujours les
enfants
finalement qui a signé le sont pas les
adultes qui assimile je voulais dit tout
à l'heure la première génération les
gens qui vont sentent obligés souvent de
déplacé dans un autre pays pour faire
refaire leur vie
le font pas tellement de gaieté de coeur
la part des gens aiment beaucoup
disons en voyage et se déplacer même
travaillé quelque temps à l'étranger
mais en général les gens aiment beaucoup
rossi rentrée dans l'eure dans leur pays
le pays de l'or leur enfance non quand
ils le font ils le font contraint et
forcé et ce sont leurs enfants
finalement qui peuvent devenir français
mais pour que ces emplois de pilotes
français
encore faut-il qu'ils soient assimilés
par d'autres enfants et donc il faut
qu'il y ait une croissance démographique
suffisante un taux de fécondité
suffisant il faut en fait que les femmes
indigènes les femmes françaises
d'origine européenne face au moins 2
enfants par femme de sorte que l'on
trouve dans les classes
quand il dans les petites classes
suffisamment d'enfants français pour que
non seulement le niveau de langue les
moeurs des façons de faire les façons de
penser
oui il ya un modèle majoritaire et une
minorité qui entraîne entre guillemets
se met à l'école de la majorité c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne
sinon vous avez des communauté
d'expatriés qui reste entre elle et le
système est bloqué donc je pense que
c'est un problème majeur c'est un
problème qui n'a jamais été finalement
soumis dans un système dans un
pourtant dans notre république
démocratique qui n'a jamais été soumise
au vote et je pense que c'est parce que
le front national a bloqué pendant très
longtemps le débat l'a rendu tabou et
donc aborder cette question c'était de
toute façon être d'extrême droite et
derrière il faut évoquer une autre
question qui est qui et le souvenir
traumatisant on peut dire de la seconde
guerre mondiale notamment le
comportement
dd delà des autorités françaises
l'administration de la police et du
gouvernement bien sûr de vichy en frac
en disons les enfants juive en traquant
les juifs les étrangers d'ailleurs les
combattants espagnols des juifs
allemands qui étaient livrés à
l'occupant et bien sûr la déportation
des juifs qui était ordonnée par
l'occupant allemand et exécuter manière
zélée
parce ce gouvernement assez épouvantable
européiste en diable et anti
souverainiste en diable qui était
quitter vichy
donc ce gouvernement là il a laissé dans
la haute fonction publique mais aussi
peut-être dans la classe dirigeante
française une empreinte traumatique de
sorte que l'on a très longtemps compris
ou symboliquement vu les enfants de
l'immigration entité des bêtises alors
attention aux patrons s'en prend à eux
parce que finalement ce sont les
descendants symbolique que des porteurs
des toiles journée puis contrôler les
papiers des étrangers vous rendez compte
ça fait penser à vichy et puis renvoyés
chez eux les étrangers dans des charters
les bateaux etc
ce serait vraiment de la déportation
j'ouvre une parenthèse aux états unis
d'amérique
même si vous êtes un ressortissant 10
ans français ou japonais part d'un pays
un pays très riche
si vous n'avez pas de droit à rester sur
le territoire américain
vous pouvez être sujet et l'objet d'une
procédure de déportation ça s'appelle
comme ça aux états unis ça veut dire
simplement où vous attrape on constate
que vous n'avez pas de papiers vous avez
pas droit de rester aux états unis et on
va vous renvoyer dans un avion chez vous
ça passe même pas par un juge d'ailleurs
donc on voit que n'importe quel pays
démocratique et a fortiori démocratique
mais n'importe quel pays on va dire
normal bien contrôler qui rentre sur son
territoire et vérifier que les étrangers
sur son territoire ont le droit de
rester et pas un pays n'est pas un un
moulin à que je sache
alors je vais changer un petit peu de
thématiques dans vos analyses monsieur
bigot vous pointez souvent du doigt les
responsabilités de l'union européenne
dans les difficultés que traverse la
france et en particulier les états
nations selon vous la citoyenneté
européenne qui s'ajoute à notre
citoyenneté française
est ce qu'elle promeut un certain
multiculture multiculturalisme pardon
qui ne favoriserait pas l'assimilation
des immigrés en europe
et en france c'est une question vraiment
très intéressante qui est rarement et
finalement rarement abordés d'abord je
sais bien qu'on parle de citoyenneté
européenne on parle même maintenant de
souveraineté européenne
mais si les mots ont un sens ce n'est ce
sont des visions des slogans au mieux
des slogans et peut-être même des
oxymores c'est à dire qu'en fait la
citoyenneté
ça fait appel la cité la cité qui vient
décision d'athènes ou dans une autre
version de rome suppose non seulement un
civisme mais ce que les dates à ce que
les romains appelaient un affectio
societatis c'est à dire le fait que les
membres d'une collectivité se regarde
les uns des autres comme si non des
frères du moins des gens qui sont liés
par un même attachement un même
attachement affectif et en fait sont des
concitoyens et des compatriotes alors le
modèle la cité n'est pas tout à fait
celui de l'état nation mais il y a en
commun entre la cité l'état nation
disons une affection societatis
concrètement et on parle beaucoup de
vivre ensemble ça me semble intéressant
ce terme de vivre ensemble c'est presque
quelque chose assez inconscient parce
qu'en réalité le fondement du civisme
depuis athènes jusqu'à rome et jusqu'à
nous
c'est pas du tout le vivre ensemble
c'est le mourir ensemble au contraire
c'est à dire que non pas qu'on ait envie
de mourir
bien sûr que non mais si la cité venait
à être attaqué alors on serait prêt à
verser dans son ensemble et c'est le
sang versé ensemble pour défendre une
cité pour défendre aussi donc à un
ensemble de valeurs politiques mais
aussi de disons un territoire charnelle
mais aussi une culture mais aussi une
langue mais aussi une civilisation mais
aussi une histoire un héritage un destin
en commun
c'est ça qui font de la cité si vous
allez sur le aujourd'hui
en 2021 sur le site de la bataille des
thermopyles vous verrez qu'il ya encore
un panneau tracé dans la dans la roche
en grec ancien qui est dit ou vous
pouvez lire passe en passant on va dire
à sparte que tes enfants sont morts pour
que ces lois vive
c'est ça la citoyenneté c'est rien
d'autre donc personne n'ira mûri pour la
zone euro personne ne m'aura pour le
drapeau européen ça je peux vous le
garantir donc c'est une idée qui peut
être sympathique ça peut être une utopie
etc
mais ce n'est pas de la même nature que
le lien civique
or une fois ce préambule est terminée
jeu consiste insiste pour dire qu'il ya
une utopie et encore une fois c'est
utopique ne me paraît pas antipathique
et c'est même une utopie sympathique et
que cette utopie européenne consiste
précisément à vouloir finalement en fait
des tâches et une loyauté juridique ou
une appartenance disons à un ensemble
politique et juridique de la détacher
disons d'une loyauté ou d'une
appartenance culturelle
je m'explique si l'union européenne et
donc l'europe en tant que utopie devait
se réaliser devait être fonctionner un
jour autrement dit si on arrivait
vraiment un état européen
ça voudrait dire quoi ça voudrait dire
que un irlandais il serait chez lui en
grèce il serait dans son pays en grèce
et un grain qui serait dans son pays en
irlande l'armée
mais ce serait formidable je ne dis pas
que ce serait mauvais je dis simplement
que c'est une utopie c'est pas du tout
du domaine du réel et que par ailleurs
évidemment on peut considérer c'est ce
que les pères fondateurs de l'europe
qu'il y a
disons un civilisation paria pour moi
n'est pas une situation il ya des
civilisations européennes mais et des
cultures européennes mais grosso modo
qu'il ya des points communs ou des
caractéristiques communes entre les
nations européennes
j'insiste pour dire que c'est
caractéristique commune voulait
retrouver par exemple les italiens et
les néo-zélandais sont aussi proches
disons que les italiens des norvégiens
bon donc il n'y a pas spécifiquement
quelque chose de propre à cette
géographie européenne
plus loin ils ont un univers occidental
est un univers judéo chrétien occidental
mais passons disons que vous voyez bien
que cette volonté de détacher la
l'appartenance à une cité à un ensemble
politique de le détacher de
l'appartenance avait une culture à une
langue à des moeurs mais aussi et
surtout peut-être à une histoire
singulière un destin historique
eh bien ça ça va immédiatement créé un
problème avec l'immigration pourquoi
tout simplement parce que le phénomène
d'assimilation dont vous ai dit tout à
l'heure c'était un phénomène assez
douloureux assez complet assez complexe
d'un point de vue humain il faut
s'arracher disons par le deuil un peu de
son pays d'origine
on n'est pas obligé de le renier
contrairement à ce qu'on entend ici ou
là et enfin grosso modo il faut se faire
à un autre pays
en vous lisez les auteurs comme hannah
arendt bondé contre 7,8 allemande
c'est surtout allemandes en réalité aux
états unis elle a beau avoir il n'a pas
eu à voir là la shoah il ya eu elle a
passé quand même une grande partie de sa
vie aux états unis ali a été bien
accueilli c'est devenu une très grande
universitaires etc
mais enfin quand vous la lisez vous
voyez bien qu'il ya des feuilles de
l'arrachement à au pays de au pays de
l'enfance donc si vous voulez cet effort
là il n'est plus requis grâce à l'europe
et il n'est plus possible grâce à
l'europe non plus puisqu'on vous dit
finalement qu en europe les grecs sont
chez eux en norvège les norvégiens sont
chez eux en grec en grèce pardon donc si
vous venez d'algérie n'est du mali
pourquoi vous avez besoin de faire un
effort finalement vous pouvez rester un
peu comme mcdonald's vous venez comme
vous êtes
voilà donc vous restez ce que vous êtes
à l'origine tout en habitant en europe
en devenant un citoyen d'europe ça vous
évite d'avoir ce chemin disons
civilisationnel culturel
c'est vrai pour les moeurs des façons de
faire et les façons de vivre les façons
de manger etc
mais c'est vrai aussi et surtout au plan
historique c'est à dire que vous ne vous
inscrivez plus dans un destin ans le
destin d'un peuple qui a un passé un
présent et un avenir
vous êtes et d'ailleurs c'est une utopie
dans lequel on sort quasiment l'histoire
je pense que j'ai dit une formule un peu
brutale que l'union européenne paraît
cet être non seulement un une
organisation internationale qui
montèrent que sur ses ergots
qui jouaient aux et horn c'est pas un
état mais surtout surtout c'est une
sorte d pape de l'histoire c'est à dire
c'est vraiment une réunion de peuples
qui n'ont plus envie du fracas et du
tumulte d'histoire on peut d'ailleurs le
comprendre mais grosso modo là où ça
devient une utopie dangereuse c'est que
bien sûr le reste du monde continue à
vivre dans le dans l'histoire c'est à
dire de manière souvent conflictuelles
alors merci pour continuer justement sur
le deuxième point que vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure on se souvient de la fameuse
phrase de bruno le maire qui souhaitait
que tous les jeunes se disent [ __ ]
être français c'est la classe mais
justement est ce que aujourd'hui la
france ou encore rêver est ce que c'est
vraiment la classe que les gens cette
impression est ce qu'on n'a pas une
déconsidération de notre propre culture
et ce particulièrement par nos élites et
nos gouvernants qui font que l'identité
française se déprécie et le cas de la
commémoration du bicentenaire de
napoléon étant un exemple flagrant de
cette honte vous parlez donc ce terme
est très fort mais mais en ce qui
concerne la classe dirigeante il est
peut-être pas pas si ils ont en outre
ans y est que ça et il ya quelque chose
il ya quelque chose de cette de cet
ordre de cet ordre-là de cet ordre là
bas on parlait de l'assimilation tout à
l'heure mais c'est vrai que sinon ce
travail de deuil qui est l'assimilation
c'était fort qui est requis qu'en plus
vous envoyez vos enfants à l'école que
vous appartenez un pays qui sait des
colonisés imaginons que vous soyez
algérien donc la colonisation de
l'algérie a pas vraiment été une
promenade de santé s'était en plus une
colonisation de peuplement et pas de
cadres donc à la lys et des la guerre
d'algérie était une guerre civile un
très très violent très douloureuse
donc tout ça est compliqué et vous
envoyez vos enfants à l'école dans
l'espoir d'être français et là on leur
apprend que la france est horrible c'est
une marâtre aller très dur alors bon moi
j'ai regardé j'ai des enfants on
achetait aller au collège
donc j'ai regardé un peu les manuels
d'histoire bon les bras vous en tombent
d'abord il ya plus aucune chronologie
tout ça n'a ni queue ni tête
il n'y a pas de barbe ont non pas que je
prenons l'exemple on parlait du civisme
tout à l'heure dans un manuel
je crois de classe de 3e si ma mémoire
est bonne j'ai vu donc il était question
de comparer la citoyenneté française à
la citoyenneté grecque
ce qu'ils faisaient il est où toute
l'histoire de l'humanité on en une année
c'est pas c'est pas un exercice
il est intéressant de comparer la
citoyenneté française à la citoyenneté
grecque pas du tout il ya beaucoup de
choses il y aurait beaucoup de chose à
en dire mais voyez bien que c'est un
problème de spécialistes c'est à dire
que quand vous avez appris l'histoire
chronologique quand vous savez à peu
près repéré disons athènes
et puis vous avez appris les bases de la
cité de la cité antique
vous pouvez comparer des choses pour
pour les comparer deux choses il faut
déjà les connaître séparément on peut
est vraiment une énorme confusion donc
il ya une confusion il n'y a pas de
repères et je pense que c'est quasiment
à dessein finalement et puis il ya aussi
cette idée de se flageller de s'auto
flageller
finalement c'est quand même très
français c'est à dire que c est la
france
la mentalité la psychologie française
elle est caractérisée par des espèces de
montagnes russes des oscillations
certeau c'est le pays de napoléon c'est
le pays d' inédit zidane c'est le pays
de charles de gaulle et puis c'est aussi
le pays voilà de l'équipe de france en
afrique du sud c'est aussi le pays de
laval c'est aussi le pays de françois
hollande et ses princes et je ne compare
pas aux landes à laval sur le plan
politique j'ai simplement cahill voulons
bien une espèce de voile à de dégoût de
soi collectif de se trouver finalement
soit beaucoup plus beaux soient beaucoup
plus laid on est en réalité il ya
quelque chose d'un peu irréaliste soit
excessivement glorieux soit
excessivement repoussant dans la façon
dont les françaises se représentent
eux-mêmes et je crois qu'en réalité
c'est un pays qui est capable
effectivement de prouesses absolument
étonnante incroyable il ya une baisse de
furia francese il ya quelque chose comme
c'est un pays à la fois latin et ça paye
à la fois nord
les deux qualités à mon avis se
neutralisent le l'autre ou alors se
transforme de l'ours mais ça arrive
finalement assez rarement
et dans le cas dans le cas contraire
finalement nous on est on a toujours
tendance à se comparer alors se comparer
ces se consoler quand on se compare
peut-être à l'étranger mais en tout cas
se comparer ces se désole quand on se
compare aux pages si vous voulez les
plus glorieuses de l'histoire de france
est quelque chose de da c'est intimidant
on le voit dans le jeu politique
aujourd'hui il faut trouver le général
de gaulle on n'en trouve pas tous tes
seins tous les tous les tous les tous
les matins général de gaulle c'est un
personnage presque digne d'un héros
antiques donc des personnages de ce type
on en a peut-être un ou deux par siècle
et grand maximum donc il ya quelque
chose comme ça et 7,7 secondes dont vous
parlez paradoxalement c'est très
français est alors évidemment les jeunes
issus de l'immigration avec un
cheminement encore plus complexe et
particuliers avec aussi la possibilité
de trouver dans l'islamisme par exemple
un récit valorisant un héroïsme une
identité collective forte des raisons de
croire en soi et de se sentir plus fort
parce qu'on appartient à un groupe
existe donc autant ça leur est dénié
dans france en tant que français
puisqu'ils sont aussi français
contrairement à ce qu'ils se racontent à
eux mêmes et ils sont notamment en
france 7 dans l'eure cape morizet la
france et dans leur mépris de la france
il exprime de manière beaucoup plus
violente est beaucoup plus grossières
que ne le font nos élites mais enfin
quand vous entendez un monsieur un jean
claude trichet ou un jean marie messier
dire iam note frenchman quand vous
écoutez le président de la république à
2 heures du matin avec un drapeau
américain derrière lui s'adresser à
l'amérique où vous l'entendez encore
plus récemment sur la chaîne cbs dire
qu'il faut déconstruire vous en tombent
en fait ça n'existerait dans aucun autre
pays donc finalement il ya quelque chose
de très français dans le fait de se
détester soi même de se comparer à des à
des moments de grandeur des moments
d'exception
il ya une exigence il voulait à être
français qui peut facilement des prix
mais mais mais je pense pas
du tout pour souvent voyagé à l'étranger
que cette idée très dévalorisée de la
france soit partagée à l'étranger en
fait nous sommes peut-être les derniers
dans le monde à ne pas croire dans la
france pour plein de raisons d'abord
parce que vous savez sans doute nos dons
jeunes cadres sont très très apprécié
par tous et dans la silicon valley pour
rencontrer énormément de français
d'ailleurs les studios pixar ont
énormément de français vous allez à la
bourse de londres détourner la
mondialisation pour énormément de
français je t'ai à singapour aussi dans
les entreprises vont rompre énormément
de français et ainsi de suite
donc finalement si on était six nuls on
se demande bien pourquoi nos cadres et
nos jeunes s'expatriera aussi bien mais
cette expatriation et notamment des
élites françaises
et quand même un signal aussi quelque
chose d'un peu répulsif maintenant en
france deuxième
deuxième idée je pense que on comprend
pas non plus que les lycées français
notamment l'enseignement supérieur on
pourra en dire un mot mais peut-être
moins moins vrai les lycées français le
secondaire dans des pays bas je compte
trois pays un trois pays qui sont quand
même très très intéressant au plan
international la russie la chine et les
états unis
le lycée français de pékin le lycée
français de washington et lycée français
de moscou ont des caractéristiques que
les français peinent eux ne savent pas
ne connaissent pas c'est d'attirer les
enfants de la classe dirigeante
beaucoup de gens du département d'état
beaucoup de gens des grandes entreprises
américaines et gratins américain on
dirait envoient leurs enfants au lycée
français de washington c'est très chic
d'aller au lycée français washington la
langue française et considérait toujours
comme une langue des élites donc voyez
il y a que non finalement pour pour ne
plus croire en nous et puis il ya une
autre raison qui est me paraissent
évidentes qui est qu en fait aujourd'hui
vous avez deux modèles qui sont
dominants vous avez le modèle chinois et
le modèle américain
le modèle chinois est un modèle ultra
collectiviste qui écrase d'individus où
l'état est vraiment très très puissants
comme en france d'ailleurs
mais où il ya vraiment pas beaucoup d'un
de créativité individuelle c'est quand
même assez oppressant d'être chinois en
dépit de tous les succès collectifs que
peut connaître la chine et puis vous
avez le modèle américain
et là c'est l'excès c'est une société
assez brutal les individus sont vraiment
un peu livrés à eux-mêmes où
l'individualisme et la compétition
individuelle est exacerbée et où grosso
modo vous savez il ya une île il ya un
état central qui est très faible les
infrastructures trump peut-être les
trucs le moins idiots qui les fait en
dehors de faire un bras de fer
commercial avec la chine ce qui a
fonctionné mais c'était de dire
maintenant il ya un gros problème avec
les infrastructures aux états unis et
c'est c'était vrai il a commencé à
investir là dedans mais on voit bien
finalement qu'il ya deux modèles et que
la france elle pourrait à condition de
reprendre confiance en elles être assez
naturellement un pays non seulement
qu'ils seraient sur le plan géopolitique
si elles réinvestissent est dans son
armée si elle disait sans réseau
diplomatique et qu'elles avaient ils ont
une volonté une indépendance un courage
aussi de cesser de jouer c'est cette
comédie absolument cette pantalonnade
ridicule qu est l union européenne qui
n'est autre que se mettre à la remorque
de l'amérique en fait si la france
redevenue elle même elle aurait vraiment
une carte à jouer dans cette tension
entre les états unis la chine qui va
faire et puis sur elle semblait l'ami
chemin où finalement l'état investit où
il y à une intervention filet social de
sécurité mais où aussi on a quand même
disons une beaucoup de considération
pour l'esprit critique pour trop
d'erreurs parfois pour la créativité
pour l'individualité pas c'est pas un
pays aussi étouffante la chine bien que
l'état soit important voyez souvent je
dis pas que évidemment mais souvent les
choses sur une question de perspective
c'est à dire que soit vous considérez
que la fameuse exception française c'est
un boulet c'est quelque chose qui nous
ralentit c'est ce qui fait qu'on est les
derniers de la classe soit au contraire
vous décidez de faire de judo c'est à
dire vous décidez de faire vos
faiblesses de vos faiblesses des forces
mais ça suppose que les élites
françaises soient vraiment des élites
qu'elles aient quelque chose dans la
tête qu'elle réfléchisse qu'elles se
mettent à se projeter à 10 ans à 20 ans
et qu'elle cesse aussi par exemple de se
mettre sur le
hérin de l'adversaire parce que quand
vous mettez sur le terrain d'être
derrière évidemment en général les
règles du jeu elles ne sont pas faites
pour vous elles sont peut-être par
l'adversaire qui a fabriqué ses propres
règles ses propres disciples et c'est
alors les choses évidemment sont pas si
simples que ça c'est pas il ya sa
demande évidemment énormément d'efforts
c'est pas en claquant des doigts et en
disant on est les meilleurs du monde
on est les champions on est un parent
pour le monde on va y arriver ça
nécessite de remobiliser tout un pays de
toute une énergie de remettre les gens
au travail
c'est quelque chose qui va prendre des
décennies sans doute mais qui vaut la
peine d'être fait parce que notre pays
nous sommes je répète les derniers enfin
nous sommes les seuls pratiquement dans
le monde pensait que la france n'a
aucune importance
au lendemain des attentats de charlie ça
a été beaucoup diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya un lecteur du new york
times qui a écrit lettre c'est
bouleversant dans dix ans mais
finalement on comprend bien pourquoi ces
djihadistes attaque à la france parce
que la france symbolise tout ce qui fait
qu'on toutes les toutes les raisons
disons de vivre et la liberté par
essence
voyez cette ce conflit aussi de
civilisation auquel on se retrouve entre
l'islamisme agressif et conquérant et un
modèle vision occidentale qui est un peu
sur le sur le recul la france est aux
avant-postes aussi de ça mais la france
serait aux avant-postes de bien d'autres
combats qui sont des combats planétaire
c'est à dire que penser à un phénomène
dont on ne parle jamais c'est à dire le
vieillissement et l'effondrement de la
population urbaine ce qu'on parle tout
le temps de l'explosion la population
humaine du problème du gaz carbonique du
réchauffement de l'est et ses stars ça
devient littéralement obsessionnelle
mais en fait si on se projette à long
terme et ça prouve d'ailleurs que nous
n'avons plus de vision à long terme
c'est à dire que nous ne voulons plus
vivre finalement en tant que
civilisation en tant que nation d'autres
sociétés en tout cas nos élites elle
n'arrive pas à se projeter bien on se
rend compte qu'en fait le problème
majeur de l'humanité aujourd'hui c'est
pas l'explosion de la population
ça va être assez rapidement son
vieillissement alors c'est vrai dans des
pays comme le japon c'est vrai dans des
pays comme l'italie l'allemagne la
plupart des pays européens d'ailleurs
c'est à dire que les femmes font moins
de deux enfants par femme
quand il y a disons rajeunissement
brutale de la population et l'explosion
population ça va ensemble sacré l'étape
problème que on a bien connu à nous mais
nos aïeux ont bien connu des révolutions
des guerres etc
mais quand il ya un vieillissement de la
population autrement dit quand les
femmes sont moins de deux enfants 1,2
1,3 au japon en chine aussi en allemagne
qu'est ce qui se passe à lille ce pas ce
qu'il y à beaucoup plus la population va
diminuer bien sûr mais surtout alors on
peut dire bon c'est pas plus mal puisque
finalement on est trop nombreux
oui sauf que ça un autre effet cette
fois ci pas quantitatif mais qualitatif
c'est qu'il va y avoir d'un seul coup
énormément de vieux en proportion par
rapport aux jeunes et là on rentre dans
un univers à mon avis très morbide c'est
le monde des ehpad dont on a presque à
un petit avant goût enfin
finalement cette espèce de sueur
mobilisation autour du pot vide ça
révéler qu'on était rentré dans un monde
très très vieillissant et s'éteint c'est
un univers dans la vie du cauchemar
autant le rajeunissement de la
population n'est pas terrible explosion
démographique le rajeunissement de la
population c'est très instable c'est
vrai mais on peut s'en sortir
tandis que le vieillissement de la
population vous rentrez dans un
mécanisme d'une certaine façon qui est
presque irrécupérable pourquoi d'abord
vous avez les problèmes de financement
des retraites on l'a vu est ce que vous
imaginez un chinois demain qui va
pousser les chaînes roulant de deux
chinois
je reviens à cette histoire de toute
fécondité sert le nombre d'enfants par
table nombre d'enfants par femme
c'est un indicateur intéressant parce
que quand vous êtes à deux tout le monde
peut logiquement comprendre l'homme et
la femme
on se reproduire faisant deux enfants
une fois que l'homme et la femme qui ont
fait des enfants sont morts ils seront
remplacés par deux personnes
la population reste stable si la femme
paie trois quatre ou cinq enfants bien
la population va grandir si la femme
fait moins de deux enfants la population
va diminuer mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'en structure par âge vous allez avoir
dans un car autant de jeunes que de
vieux deux femmes deux enfants par femme
plus de jeunes que de vieux 3 ou 4
enfants par femme
et puis moins de deux enfants par femme
plus de vieux que de jeunes et c'est un
à mon avis un environnement
particulièrement délétère affreux où il
y aura ralentissement de la créativité
ralentissement disons de la croissance
et
nick on peut aussi considérer qu'il
allait boire c'est un monde voilà on va
parler de maladies tout le temps de
traitement par balancer le monde
la planète va tenir un gigantesque ehpad
est un cauchemar
alors quoi je parle de la france ne
passe que la france est une nation qui
qui a l'avait dit long ça a été touché
le quotient familial a été touché mais
on a encore des crèches on a encore
toutes sortes de choses qui sont très
originales au plan de la planète
on a une politique qui permet en fait
aux femmes à la fois de faire des
enfants est à la fois de travailler et
ça c'est une clé pour l'humanité je dis
bien pour l'humanité et sert que la
france a des solutions pour la planète
entière
parce que si dans le monde entier on a
on aime finalement on ne conçoit pas un
environnement qu'elle est femme connaît
à la fois à travailler et faire des
enfants et bien le monde va s'écrouler
sur lui même en fait il va y avoir une
sorte d'implosion démographique un
vieillissement qui sera tragique de
l'humanité mais on pourrait prendre
mille et un sujets sur lesquels à mon
avis qui montrerait que la france n'a
véritablement un boulevard atteignait se
redonner un peu les moyens dernier
exemple peut-être la rn message est
peut-être que vous ne le savez pas mais
vérifiez le sur internet c'est en 1993
que des cas un médecin français a déposé
le brevet de de la rn messager qui
s'était repris ensuite par une
chercheuse en hongrois émigré aux états
unis mais bon voilà c'est si on faisait
la généalogie de toutes les inventions
de toutes les choses qui ont transformé
le monde même dans les 10 20 dernières
années
j'aurais extrêmement surpris de voir à
quel point la france est alors dans
cette longue réponse monsieur niveau
vous avez marre d'être trop longue
non c'est pas ça pas de soucis vous avez
bien détaillé justement la réponse à la
question sur sur notre honte comme
pierre le mentionner de cette culture et
cette histoire française
alors dans cette réponse vous avez
également évoqué notre rapport aux états
unis notre comparaison avec les modèles
étrangers et ça me permet de rebondir
sur cette américanisation notre société
que certains dénoncent qui influencent
aussi grandement notre rapport à
l'identité à l'intégration des minorités
voilà il ya des concepts qui deviennent
très en vogue comme la cancel culture le
mouvement groupe
donc voilà ça c'est des concepts qui
sont directement 1
planté via la société américaine
certains considèrent d'ailleurs le
modèle républicain assimilationniste
comme profondément injuste voire
discriminant voire violent est ce que
vous pensez qu'il est encore possible de
promouvoir ce modèle républicain
assimilationniste dans ce 21e siècle qui
devient de plus en plus individualiste
comme vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs dans
votre explication du modèle états unis
en fait je pense que le une partie de
comment on pourrait dire de l'ornière où
du point mort dans lequel on se retrouve
sur le plan politique c'est qu'on est
comme on dit chez allen jouer avec cet
anglicisme qu'on est contestée bousculer
de l'extérieur par l'importation d'un
certain nombre de modèles le mode à
l'italie c'est vrai le modèle américain
etc qui sont pas une autre et que nous
n'avons quand je dis nous les français
et qui croient à la france nous et en
particulier disons qu'on sait les
souverainistes j'aime pas trop ce terme
est bon nous n'avons qu'à opposé à
opposer qu'un modèle disons qui
appartient au passé et qui serait figé
dans le temps est valable toute
l'éternité n'en voyez bien qu'il ya
quelque chose qui n'est pas réaliste là
dedans parce qu on ne se baigne jamais
deux fois dans un club et parce que
lorsqu'on vous conteste
lorsqu'on vous bouscule lorsqu'on vous
challenge si vous ne répondez pas au
challenge si vous ne répondez pas aux
questions qu'on vous pose si vous
répondez pas aux défis si vous ne fait
pas la démonstration que votre modèle
est meilleur en fait c'est à dire que
vous êtes arquebouté crispé sur un
modèle du passé
c'est ça qui se produit en fait c'est
que je pense que nous sommes dans le
vrai le modèle républicain universaliste
absolument dans le bref la france avec
son identité beaucoup de choses à
apporter au monde mais évidemment il
faut qu'elle fasse une sorte d'âge d'or
on amène tôt il faut qu'elle se met à la
page il faut qu elle actualise son
logiciel et pour ça il ne faut en aucun
cas laisser c'est disons ses modèles aux
qui nous conte est de l'extérieur nous
leur laisser disons l'illusion qu'il
représente à venir ou qu'il représente
l'évolution naturelle de l'histoire
voyez il ya vraiment une dialectique
naturel lorsque le parlementarisme
anglais britannique ont été agressés par
le troisième reich
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça a pris un
peu plus de temps en france où général
de gaulle est revenue aux affaires plus
tard aux états unis notamment parlé du
parlementaire anglais et français mais
ses dreads da grande démocratie
américaine ce soir roosevelt de gaulle
ou churchill
ils ont renforcé le pouvoir exécutif ils
ont renforcé considérablement
ils ont arrêté de faire de la
politicaillerie avec une instabilité
parlementaires des petites combines et
sione politique etc
en fait il ya quelque chose quand vous
êtes attaqué militairement mais aussi
intellectuellement et bien il ya
toujours quelque chose à apprendre de
votre ennemi à apprendre et apprendre
donc nous n'avons résisté à hitler que
parce que nous avons bombardé au sol
rasés au sol bombes incendiaires
l'évident allemand donc nous avons
appris d'hitler la brutalité et nous
l'avons renvoyé sa brutalité
si nous n'avions pas brutaliser
l'allemagne même si c'est jusque jeudi
et très politiquement incorrect
j'entends eric zemmour s'étrangler
d'indignation parce que les soldats
soviétiques ont violé les femmes à
berlin bien sûr mais réponse du berger à
la bergère
il y avait quatorze mille huit cents
ouradour sur glane en ukraine en russie
des imaginaires des villages avec femme
enfants étaient à brûler et mais qu'est
ce que vous pensez qu'on peut les
soldats soviétiques
donc c'est d'une certaine façon oui
hitler après la brutalité ou démocratie
et de démocratie ont appris à se battre
le dos au mur et on montre et qui
finalement était plus brutale c'est pas
ça qui fait qu'on a raison ce qui fait
qu'on a raison c'est que notre système
de valeurs et notre système politique
sont supérieurs mais on a appris une
leçon et on a été capable de se
transformer dans une vision beaucoup
plus pacifique est beaucoup plus disons
heureuse il y a le challenge où le défi
que le communisme a représenté pour le
modèle capitaliste
je vous signale que si on n'avait pas
créé la sécurité sociale si on n'avait
pas augmenté les salaires si on n'avait
pas transformé profondément le
capitalisme non seulement au lendemain
de la crise de 29
ça a pris du temps mais surtout surtout
parce que
disons en staline et l'armée rouge nous
mettait quasiment un pistolet sur la
tempe
il y avait quand même une contestation
communiste et le monde ouvrier était en
pleine ébullition à l'intérieur des pays
occidentaux aux capitalistes et bien
voilà on serait mort donc il faut
toujours se réinventer il faut toujours
se réinventer sous la pression
extérieure
il a ce qui est absolument désolant
c'est que les gens qui sont dans le vrai
des gens qui défendent la france des
gens qui défendent à dire le destin
français tel qu'il est singulier les
gens qui défendent l'universalisme
républicain
ils sont figés en fait ils sont congelés
ils ne veulent plus inventer l'avenir il
ne s' il ne cesse de faire appel d'en
appeler aux essarts noir je ne sais trop
quelle nostalgie terra mais on ne se
baigne jamais deux fois dans le même
fleuve
c'est fini le temps des lucernois il
faut repenser et des hussards noirs avec
les réseaux sociaux il faut repenser les
hussards noirs avec le défi considérable
de l'islamisme et ainsi de suite
vous voyez cet effort n'est jamais fait
en fait on ne on ne réinvente pas le
modèle français et c'est très inquiétant
parce que j'ai à vous dire que ça manque
de vie ça manque de souffle ça manque de
le désir de de conquête en quelque sorte
la meilleure défense c'est toujours la
tac
donc voilà pour la réponse était c'était
peut-être un peu long et donc dans cette
américanisation notre de notre société
on parlait d' immigration tout à l'heure
c'est typique c'est à dire que nous
sommes nos élites sont tellement a bien
organisé c'est vraiment le concept
d'aliénation au sens marxiste du terme
c'est à dire que quand quelqu'un est
vraiment aliénés et bien il ne sait même
pas qu'il est aliéné en réalité c'est à
la façon dont il a de penser les choses
elle est tellement elle s'imprègne
tellement des idées du maître dominant
que le dominer ne se rend pas compte
quand nos élites entre guillemets élites
pensent l'immigration il pense aux états
unis en fait ils pensent que la france
serait un territoire qui a toujours été
ouvert aux migrations que les français
ne seraient constituées que d'immigrés
ce qui est évidemment faux
on a beaucoup mais il n'ya pas que les
immigrés y avait si vous voulez des
apaches des comanches et des sioux qui
était archi
dominant est effectivement au xxème
siècle qu'on a reçu autant dénigrer que
les américains mais les américains ne
sont quasiment qu'une terre
d'immigration les indigènes américains
ont été clochardisé est massacrée et
milan des réserves les les indigènes
français sont largement majoritaires
donc la manière les billets si vous
voulez intellectuelle avec lesquels tous
les problèmes sont pensées sont
effectivement été en quelque sorte
laisse à penser que nos élites ont
complètement télécharger le modèle
américain pense en terme américains se
représente en terme américains les
enjeux donc ces enjeux d'immigration
effectivement là il faut faire de
l'affirmative action comme aux états
unis il faut faire il faut jouer la
carte du communautarisme et c'est comme
ça que les gens par entrisme finalement
vont se faire une place au soleil etc
enfin c'est tout ça est très très
étonnant l'union européenne c'est la
même chose finalement c'est l'idée de
faire les états unis d'europe à la mode
des états unis d'amérique avec les pères
fondateurs cour suprême avec le sénat la
chambre des représentants ya vraiment
une je pense une américanisation très
très très profonde de la classe
dirigeante française ça ça c'est sûr
merci alors nous arrivons au terme de
cette entrevue on va essayer de penser
des solutions et des lignes de réflexion
de manière un peu plus succincte
en effet on a présenté je pense les
enjeux et certains comme jérôme fourquet
parle d'archipel isation vous évoquer
cette question démographique est
essentielle mais finalement est-ce qu'il
est encore possible de recréer du lien
de refaire nation et pensez vous des
solutions pour un éventuel sursaut
français
moi je trouve que c'est très paradoxal
le diagnostic qui est qui est posée par
par fourquet j'ai lu qu'un des choses
sont sont très juste très bien vu ça
faisait penser d'ailleurs un autre
notre analyse était celle de d'emmanuel
todd où il disait finalement que les il
y avait à dire une sorte de classe comme
ça mondialisée très américanisée très
favorable à l'europe etc qui
représentait ils ont entre 20 et 30% de
la population et que contrairement aux
élites du passé qui était finalement
très peu nombreuses à avoir fait les
études supérieures comme ils étaient peu
nombreux ils étaient obligés de prendre
leur café avec les ouvriers et avec le
reste de la population comme ils étaient
trop peu nombreux ils étaient obligés de
partager 10 ont une façon d'être et de
penser
voilà donc il ya deux différences entre
cette fausse élite de 25 30% et cette
véritable élite dans le passé de 5%
d'abord c'est le niveau 1 le niveau
intellectuel éducatif et culturel qui
est pas du tout le même et d une
véritable élite est là aujourd'hui c'est
une fausse élite mais surtout une élite
massifier d'une certaine façon et toi d
assez cruel il parle de la de l'élite
télérama ou la gauche télérama mais il
ya l'autre chose c'est qu'ils sont
suffisamment nombreux pour vivre à part
et donc c'est le propose pour quelqu'un
qui dit finalement les gens ils vivent
complètement à part alors ce n'est pas
totalement faux mais poussons le
raisonnement en fait je pense que on a
une espèce de tonna identitaire qui
n'est pas celle que décrit madame
chapeau monsieur macron elle est très
différente mais elle est néanmoins à mon
avis très très dangereuse cette tenaille
identitaire c'est vous avez deux parties
de la société française qui font un peu
bande à part vous avez effectivement
c'est ces fameux quartiers ghettos avec
du trafic de stupéfiants qui sont
réalistes la mise et l'idéologie des
colonials fait que jeter de l'huile sur
le feu et donc là il ya quelque chose de
très vindicatif alors faut pas raison
garder c'est pas belfast n'est pas la
guerre civile inclus
c'est pas on pourrait dire il y a quand
même une sorte de une sorte de derrick
territoriales c'est sûr donc là il ya
une remise en cause mais ça correspond à
quelle quantité quelle portion du
territoire
si vous regardez certains endroits par
la ville de la courneuve
effectivement on est diplômé c'est fini
c'est foutu bon mais il ya des taches de
léopard
ça où il est effectivement des des
minorités qui font la loi et qui se
détache du territoire mais c'est pas
l'ensemble du territoire national et si
vous prenez un peu de champ et un peu de
leur jeu vous rendez compte que c'est
peut-être aller 10 % 5 % c'est très
difficile à estimer
et les gens qui sont vraiment vindicatif
et agressif là dedans ils sont encore
moins nombreux et de l'autre côté de
l'échelle sociale à l'autre extrémité de
l'échelle sociale
vous avez effectivement on appelle un
peu facilement les bobos qui votent
disons pour la mondialisation et la
globalisation l'europe la république en
marche un petit coup de l air un petit
plus de pse modo ça avec les écolos bien
sûr et ces jours là ils sont combien 25%
20-25 à tout casser 30%
donc finalement on se rend compte qu'il
y à 30% de la société d'un côté qui a
envie de faire bande à part qui ne
croient plus à la france alors de
manière violente ou de manière très
pacifique avec une bise ont l'idée d'un
village global
mais contrairement à ce que pense
monsieur fourquet il y a quand même 70
peut-être 80 % des français toutes
classes sociales confondues probablement
toutes origines et toutes religions
confondues qui sont encore très attachés
à la france et qui partagent énormément
de diagnostic en commun d'idées en
commun etc
je pense que le pays est quand même
peut-être plus unique il l'a jamais été
en fait donc il ya beaucoup de raisons
d'espérer
ce qui est le plus frappant c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de vectorisation politique de
ça il n'y a pas peut-être que c'est
parce qu'aux tables qui est un parti de
78 80 % c'est parce que je dis ça
tuerait la démocratie sans doute mais
c'est vraiment frappant de voir que
c'est pas porté politiquement ou s'est
pas portée par un discours disons 13 ans
ou enthousiasmant si on peut considérer
que le rassemblement national serait le
moins éloignés de ceux de ce que je vous
dis ce que je vous raconte
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même
il y à un archi il ya une archipel
isation de la société mais il ya aussi
une sorte de alors je vais tomber dans
ce que je dénonce lui utiliser un terme
anglo saxon il ya un mainstream très
très très important j'ajoute que les
classes dirigeantes suivent leurs
intérêts et qu'aujourd'hui évidemment
leur intérêt compte tenu des règles du
jeu économique c'est de favoriser la
mondialisation c'est normal quand vous
êtes non seulement à la tête de lvmh
êtes un cadre qui travaillent dix ans
dans des entreprises dont l'essentiel de
la richesse se fait à l'exportation
regardez la structuration du cac 40 un
îlot où ils font leurs profits bah oui
vous avez intérêt à jouer contre votre
pays c'est normal ce sont les règles du
jeu imposées par le politique et à
l'autre extrémité est donc là ces gens
là aujourd'hui ils servent leurs
intérêts mais si vous changez les règles
du jeu ils vont aussi changé et il
pourrait il pourrait aussi changer de
perspective et l autre bout du spectre
c'est la même chose je suis prêt à
parier que dans les banlieues les
fameuses banlieue ya énormément de gens
qui subissent cette fois des racailles
bien sûr mais il ya aussi des gens ne
soyons pas naïfs qui en vivent pas ce
qu'il ya une espèce d'effet de
ruissellement finalement de ce trafic de
stupéfiants et cette mentalité de
l'islamisme elle ne concerne pas que
voyou il ya aussi des gens très bien
malheureusement qu'ils sont convaincus
par les islamistes néanmoins là aussi je
pense qu'il ya des raisons d'espérer
l'islam est une religion qui est très
très très sensible au rapport de force y
compris aux rapports de forces
militaires sur un plan théologique c'est
très pensé par l'islam et par les
savants de l'islam même dans le coran
des beaucoup de choses là dessus donc si
la france se montre disent on ne donne
pas le choix à ces immigrants et à ces
immigrés pardon que de s'assimiler ou de
partir et ne te donne pas le choix non
plus à l'islam qui est en france que de
se sentir bisons de pouvoir y vivre de
manière paisible mais pas avec un
sentiment est un comportement de
conquête pas en territoire conquis une
certaine façon moi je crois que les
choses pourraient rentrer dans l'ordre
assez assez rapidement de manière
finalement assez surprenante
il ya quelque chose que je garde
toujours à l'esprit qui ne donne
beaucoup de courage c'est de
réfléchir à l'évolution d'un pays comme
la russie qui est très très différent de
la france un modèle très autoritaire je
souhaite pas bien sûr à la france un
putin du tout ça c'est vraiment à la
mode russe mais en tout cas si on
regarde l'état de la russie en 1991 et
l'état de la russie en 2021
même si la russie n'est pas encore
beaucoup de ces matières premières peu
si la russie a encore des tas de
problèmes et surtout la russie un pays
et le reste un pays très autocratique
est très autoritaire
si on met ça de côté je peux vous
assurer que la transformation on peut
parler de renaissance la russie en 1991
c'était un pays exempt qui n'avait plus
aucune confiance en lui qui était trahi
littéralement par ses élites ou la
sécurité n'était plus assurée et le pays
était en pleine en plein effondrement
autant effondrement or le pays s'est
complètement repris merci beaucoup
monsieur bideau pour cette rentrée avec
les rentes sur le thème général de
l'assimilation culturelle pour toutes
vos réponses claires et pertinentes
nous avons pu évoquer beaucoup de
thématiques lors de cette heure des
changes qui vont de l'immigration aux
influences étrangères à l'identité
l'histoire de france en passant par la
démographie
donc je laisse le mot de la fin à pierre
et je vous remercie à nouveau monsieur
vidéo au nom de toute l'équipe de scopeo
l'observatoire politique
merci à bout les gars merci en effet
pour ces échanges et réflexions
passionnantes sur un sujet clé qui sera
sans doute au coeur de la présidentielle
de 2000 22 en effet réfléchir anticiper
penser de manière globale ces enjeux
politiques c'est le sens de notre think
tank scopeo l'observatoire politique et
nous vous invitons à retrouver tout
notre travail sur notre site scopeo
point org merci beaucoup et à très
bientôt
merci à vous et bravo pour ce nouveau
patch merci